and there followed another angel saying
babylon is fallen is fallen
that great city
because she made all nations drink of
the wine of the wrath of her fornication
but who makes up babylon
and how is it fallen
join the word inspired
sabbath december 25 at 2 o'clock p.m
eastern standard time for a q a with
elder randy skeet on babylon
other special guests include kevin gomez
jonathan david archie and stacy and
brown
questions from the live audience will
also be taken even if not directly
related to the topic
this meeting will be hosted on zoom and
live stream to denisha mccurchien's
youtube channel personal and the word
inspired facebook pages and twitch
profile at the word inspired
links are in the description of this
video feel free to like share and
subscribe
we hope to see you there and welcome
your prayers and support as we finish
the work of the gospel
thank you and god bless
[Music]
all right welcome and happy sabbath
again everyone let us begin with a word
of prayer dear lord we come before you
unworthy undone unholy and unclean but
you are the mighty healer you are the
great i am you are the one who cleanses
us of our sins so here we are saying
father forgive us and please speak to
and through us fill us with your holy
spirit even give us an outpouring of
your early and latter reign there father
so that we can understand and apply your
truth in a special way i present before
you your manservant elder randy skeet
and i pray that you would put your words
in his mouth so that as he speaks their
lord your voice would be heard by your
people
we thank you and for here for hearing
and for answering this prayer for
preparing our hearts to receive and to
apply this your word in jesus name we
pray amen
all right joining us today is elder
randy skeet we are all familiar with him
he is an evangelist that travels all
around the world
sharing the gospel i'm not sure how much
rest he gets because he's always on the
move sharing the word but we thank god
that he is here he indeed studied for
the ministry graduated from oakwood
university and the theological seminary
at andrews university and he is here
with us today um in fact he's here on a
monthly basis in for this q and a
session and we appreciate your presence
elder skeet and we continue to pray that
god will put his words in your mouth
so friends let us listen reverend and
think as he speaks please welcome elder
randy skeet
thank you very much my good sister god
bless you again i
want to state very clearly how
privileged i am to be a part of this
program and i hope that
the program is a blessing to those who
tune in wherever you are around this
world if you're connected to this
presentation
may the lord richly bless you with light
because light is life and truth is life
and truth ultimately is christ himself
he's the living word
and so i'll say a prayer and then i'll
take the very first question father in
heaven
as we proceed with this program
answering questions we need wisdom
james chapter 1 verse 5 says if any of
you lack wisdom
let him ask of god to give it to all men
liberally and bringeth not and it shall
be given him grant us that wisdom i pray
put your words in my mouth and in the
mouths of anyone else who contributes so
that the truth may triumph to your glory
and our blessing in jesus name i pray
amen
amen amen
our first question is
what are the biblical origins of babylon
and what was its
purpose biblical origin of babylon
goes all the way back to a genesis
chapter 10 we can go there
we can read from verse 8 of genesis
chapter 10.
i'll give my listeners a couple seconds
to find it genesis 10 reading from verse
8 and anyone can read or i can read
and that's up to you dr mccarthy and let
us know what you'd prefer
and kush begat nimrod he began to be a
mighty one in the earth he was a mighty
hunter before the lord therefore it is
said even as nimrod the mighty hunted
before the lord and the beginning of his
kingdom was babel and eric and akid and
kalmei
in the land of china we have the very
first collection of cities forming a
kingdom
set up by this man called
nimrod now if you go to genesis 6
and read from verse 4 of genesis 6
and genesis 6 1 to 7 describes god's on
god's displeasure with the wicked there
were giants in the earth in those days
and also after that when the sons of god
came in unto the daughters of men and
their bear children to them the same
became mighty men which would revolt men
of renown remember this is a description
of the wicked
the just come in in verse 8 when the
bible says but noah found grace in the
eyes of the lord but from verse one to
seven we're dealing with the wicked and
we're presented with the reason why god
set the flood now in verse 4 we see that
the intermarriage produced mighty men
which of all men of renown
now if you go back to genesis 10 and you
read verse 9 he began to be a mighty one
in the earth so there seems to be
evidence that nimrod was one of those
mighty people that resulted from this
ungodly mixed marriages that god did not
sanction at all and so the beginning of
his kingdom was babel and eric and akid
and kalne
in the land of shiner and you read in
daniel 1 verses 1 and 2 the land of
china is the land of the babylonians and
so we are introduced to babylon out of
babel which means confusion of the gates
of the god were introduced as a place
where the ungodly has the rest have
their residence a place built by the
ungodly a place built by one of the
wicked mighty men by name nimrod and so
babel babylon is introduced to us as a
place of rebellion a place of opposition
to god a place where an alternate form
of worship was established
this is the origin of babylon or babel
what was his purpose well its purpose is
if god had no purpose for wicked babel
or babylon
satan had a purpose satan he uses
earthly agents to undermine the kingdom
of god and so babel babylon was simply
an agent in the hand of satan literally
back then and of course based on
revelation spiritually we have babylon
today and so god had no purpose for
wicked babel but certainly the devil had
and still has a purpose for modern day
babylon which is the undermining of the
work of god and replacing god in the
lives of people with a false system of
worship
amen amen that's babylon
yes and i you did a perfect segue into
our next question so we look at the
origins of babylon and he spoke about
nimrod
founding um babel and the other cities
now we want to talk about who comprises
babylon in these last days so we had
physical babylon back then but the bible
speaks about a babylon in the book of
revelation who comprises babylon and
what is their aim
if you go to revelation 18
now revelation 18 so in revelation 14 we
read verse 8.
we have revelation 14 8.
all good advocates should know that what
does that verse say and they followed
another angel saying what babylon
huh
because she made all nations drink of
the wine of her
fornication now
the sex says babylon is fallen now the
fall is not complete it's a progressive
fall
but when that message was given that
message was given after 1798 this is an
end time message this was not given
hundreds and hundreds of years ago this
is since 1798 that this message was
given now so it's an end time message
along with the angel of verses six and
seven and the angel of nine through
twelve so this is a message for the end
time now this could not refer only to
the payable system because the people
system has been fallen for hundreds and
hundreds of years and so babylon must
include all the protestant churches that
have compromised and adopted a large
degree the people system or the catholic
system if i can be more blunt and so
babylon is a combination of false
worship systems of which the roman
church is the largest contributor and
all other churches in professionally
protestantism have uh surrendered to
actually there was a meeting a few years
ago between catholics and protestants
and some prominent either catholic or
protestants said that revelation the
reformation is over the refuge the
reformation is done this is an evidence
of the fallen condition of babylon and
so babylon refers to a false system of
worship which includes protestantism
apostate protestants i should say and of
course the roman the roman system
so that is babylon and the fall is not
yet complete you see because god still
has people in babylon
and so he called them out in revelation
18 come out of her my people and so that
fall is not yet complete because god
still has some people in there but as a
general system
babylon which refers to false systems of
worship
they have fallen very very far and why
do i say a protestantism if you fall
you've got to fall from somewhere you
fall from a height you never fall up you
fall down when lucifer fell he fell from
above he was cast down before he fell he
occupied an exalted position
protestantism during the time of the
reformation in the 16th century they
were very much in favor with god because
they were opposing entrenched error they
did not know everything because martin
luther never kept the sabbath but he was
still a child of god they did not know
everything but they knew that the system
under which they were brought up was
false and so in its early beginnings
protestantism pleased god but after
centuries have passed protestantism have
a lot has aligned itself with the people
system and in doing that protestantism
is fallen is fallen is still falling and
it's become a major part of babylon
amen and i hope we're seeing that
connection
product protestantism fell because it
began to intermix or we can
intermarry with deception with the
papacy getting back to those doctrines
that they had left off because they were
ungodly so friends god calls us to be
separate and just to be clear remember
the first question we understood that
babylon originally its origins it's a
physical place that was built by nimrod
who did so in rebellion to god and in
these last days spiritual babylon
represents those that are in rebellion
to the word of god namely the papacy and
apostate protestantism so we we we see
that god use physical babylon as a
symbol of spiritual babylon which i
would say is even greater in these last
days let's go to genesis chapter 11
let's uh continue on babylon genesis 11
we read for verse four
from one
all right do we have that
yes and the whole earth was in one
language and one speech and it came to
pass as they journeyed from the easter
they found a plane where in the land of
china and they dwelt there and they said
once another go to let us make brick and
burn them thoroughly so they had
breakfast stone and slime and there for
morty and they said go to let us build
this a city and a tower who stopped
their race under heaven and let us make
us a name unless we scattered abroad
upon the face of the whole earth it was
god's will that mankind would occupy the
entire world the builders of babel did
not want to do that so they stated their
opposition to god's will god's will was
replenish the earth that's what he told
adam he also told moses noah the same
thing in genesis 9.
they refused that they wanted to
concentrate and so they said let us make
us a city build a city in a tower and
let us make us a name lest we be
scattered abroad they opposed the will
of god and the lord came down to see the
city and the tower which the children of
men build it god had to come down look
at it and then of course he pronounced
judgment on it verses 6 and 7 of genesis
11. and so we see flagrant opposition to
god not opposition born of ignorance but
flagrant opposition to god's system so
that we have some more introductory
material about babylon and this is the
same people who we read about in chapter
10 whose kingdom was babel eric
babel eric acked and called in the land
of china led by this infamous person
called nimrod flagrant opposition to
god's system
religious
you see
the fact that something is religious
doesn't make it good they have their
religion don't misunderstand me the
canaanites had their religion the
moabites had their religion but god was
not favorable to any of those religions
he gave the true religion to the hebrews
or to the jews or to the israelites so
the problem isn't the problem isn't uh
religion in the sense is it is it
consistent with thus said the lord and
babylon's religious system is
diametrically opposed to god's system
even though in many aspects it looks
familiar and so babylon is satan's
chosen instrument for promoting and
popularizing a system of worship that is
contrary to god
system amen amen i need not say anything
else i'm going to allow brother kevin
gomez to ask the next three questions
and these questions will zero in for the
most part on revelation 14 verse 8.
brother kevin gomez you may ask the next
set of questions thank you thank you
very much denisha it's a pleasure for me
to be
here in this program again it's always
an inspiration for me and i'm so happy
that i'm contributing to the spread of
the gospel in this way so question
number three says revelations 14 8 and
18 2 declare that babylon is fallen is
fallen what is the nature of this fall
and in what ways does the fall of
babylon in daniel 5
inform the fall in the in these last
days
all right
you say the question is what do they
fall from is that part of the question
um read it again read the whole question
okay please revelations 14 8 and 18 2
declare that babylon is falling is
falling what is the nature of this fall
that's the first part of the question
and the second part uh says in
in with sorry in what ways does the fall
of babylon in daniel 5
inform the fall
in the in these last days the nature of
the fall is a fall from truth now let's
go to first timothy chapter four let's
look at a fall or falling away first
timothy chapter four let's read verse
one then we'll go to second
thessalonians
chapter two verse three
first timothy chapter four we read verse
one
do we have that
now the spirit speaketh expressly that
in the latter time some shall depart
from the faith this is a falling now
that's what paul says in timothy here is
what paul says in 2nd thessalonians
chapter 2 verse 3 let no man deceive you
by any means for that they shall not
come except they come of falling away
first now a falling away from what you
see this falling away the world does not
fall away from anything it is the church
that falls away a falling away is a
departure from thus said the lord to us
once you depart from god you've gone to
satan there are no other choices and so
the fall of babylon is a fall from truth
a fall from the law of god a fall from
the righteousness of god as expressed in
the life of christ and in christ's lord
that fall as i say is a departure from
plain biblical truth now how does the
fall in daniel 5 inform the fall of
revelation 18 2 or 48. let's go to
daniel 5.
we read from first it in the bible the
very simple book to understand most of
it is simple if we take it as it reads
daniel 5 we shall read from verse 18.
daniel is speaking to belshazza
you know the hand appears and writes
beerus doesn't understand what's
happening and so he calls in his
magicians astrologers none can explain
only daniel could by the way the only
organization on the face of the earth
that you help people understand what's
going on is the seventh-day adventist
church not cnn or msnbc
it should be the perfect when i'm
digressing but let me do it in genesis
41 when pharaoh had two dreams he called
all his musicians all his sausays none
could explain except joseph a child of
god
when the bikinis could not understand
what he dreamt what it meant he called
daniel when belshazzar could not
understand what was happening his
magicians couldn't explain he got an
explanation from daniel i'm saying
boldly and without fear of being accused
of political incorrectness the only
organization on the face of the earth
that can rightly explain what's going on
should be the prophetic people of god
the seventh day out of this church and
having said that let's go to daniel 5
let's read from verse 18
and thou king
oh thou came
the most high god gave nebuchadnezzar
thy father a kingdom majesty and glory
and honor
and for the majesty that he gave him all
people nations and languages tremble and
seared before him whom he would he slew
and whom he would he saved the lives
whom he would he set up whom he would he
put down but when his heart was lifted
up and his mind hardened in prime he was
deposed from his kingly throne and they
took his glory from him now dennis is
explaining why belshazz is about to fall
a spiritual fall is a spiritual fall
we skipped verse 21 where we have a
description and he was driven from the
sons of man and he he had a mind like
the animal and he was you know his
dwelling was with the wild asses we go
to verse 22 but thou his son obeys
shazam has not humbled thine heart
though thou knewest all this or all
these things
daniel says you know what happened to
nebuchadnezzar by the way his
grandfather not his father you know what
happened to him and you have not humbled
your heart before god now the bible is
largely a black and white book a person
who has not humbled the heart before god
is someone who's proud and who exalts
himself above god or herself whether
directly or through a false system
belshazzar did not humble himself and so
he exalted himself now we read the very
next verse but thou has done what read
that what that verse say and thou has
what
part of the hand sent from him 24 no no
verse 20 verse 22 22.
thou hast
um
oh but has lifted up myself lifted up
myself yes yes you see i wanted to read
that that has lifted myself against the
lord of heaven and they have brought the
vessels of his house before thee and
thou and thy lord thy wife and thy
concubites have drunk white in them that
has praised now let's read carefully
that has praised the gods of silver and
gold of brass iron wood of stone which
see not now here nor no but the god in
whose hand thy breath in and whose are
all thy ways thou has not glorified this
is the reason for belshazza's fall this
was the reason for nebuchadnezzar's
fault but praise god he was given a a
second chance he fell when he said is
this not great babylon that i have built
god had nothing to do with this this is
my doing and god had to strike him down
belshazzar did not learn the lesson from
his father or great-grandfather whatever
he began as it was to him and so god
brought him down now the fall in daniel
in revelation 18 verse 2 babylon the
great is fallen is fallen why because we
can go to daniel chapter seven let's
look at reasons for the fall because
babylon's major component is the papal
system or the roman system in daniel 8
you know verse
10 speaking about this this uh this
power that we call the man of sin in
second thessalonians the lamb like beast
in uh revelation 13 the little horn in
daniel said it's the same power
he magnified himself even to the host of
heaven and cast down some of the horses
of the stars to the ground and stamped
upon them yeah he magnified himself even
to the prince of the horse this false
system challenged the very supremacy of
god
and so god had to god has to one they
destroy that system which has its roots
hundreds of years ago and so we have a
system challenging god belshazzar
challenged god because he lifted himself
against the most high god of the lord of
heaven
daniel 5 22 and so in chapter 18 of
revelation
a mighty angel came down he cried mighty
with a strong voice babylon the great is
fallen is fallen and it's become the
habitation of devils on a hold of every
foul spirit on the cage of every unclean
and hateful bird
this is a very very terrible
condemnation that god is pronouncing god
is saying a religious system
is the habitation of devils and a whole
every foul spirit
pause and think of that
the most dangerous place you can be is
the wrong church
let me say that again the most dangerous
place to be is not on a fault line in
western united states or somewhere where
earthquakes occur all the time it is to
be in the wrong church listen to how the
bible describes a religious system it's
become the habitation of devils on a
hold of every found spirit on a cage of
every unclean and hateful bird this is
the description the bible gives of
babylon which is falling and falling and
in the great controversy page 389
paragraph three alois said that fall is
not yet complete of course it will
become clear when a law is passed making
sunday the official day worship and the
churches accept it and make that choice
then the fall would have been complete
but the fall is going on but this call
is already very very catastrophic and so
we see a challenge to god's authority in
daniel 5.
we saw it in daniel 4 and god struck
down nebuchadnezzar we see it in daniel
5 god strapped down belshazza that
babylon back then was a literal babylon
the one in revelation spiritual but the
reasons are the same because whatever
upset god in the earth upsets god in the
new
putting in god's place a system that is
not of god and for this reason
god will bring down babylon about his
ears and all that make up babylon of
course the major component of babylon is
the roman system
and so daniel 5 yes gives us some clue
as to why babylon falls in daniel 18
revelation 18 also we have mentioned in
17.
okay thank you thank you very much for
the answer welcome
and i really like the part that you said
that one of the worst things were places
that we can be is in the wrong church
yes yes and we're starting right now to
learn to be in the true church in the
literal church yes you say if one of the
greatest catastrophes of ancient history
is the destruction of jerusalem and god
allowed it prior to that god allowed the
old testament uh jerusalem to be
destroyed by nebuchadnezzar why because
they departed from god and god's
commandments a departure from god's
commandments is the only reason why god
pronounces judgment he has no other
reason let me say that again a departure
from god's law is the single reason why
god unleashes his judgment and he must
and so as in the days of the the
jerusalem in daniel chapter 1 saw to
jerusalem in the new testament which was
destroyed between 1866 and 78 why
because they departed from truth when
you depart from truth you're depart from
god because rejecting truth is rejecting
the offer of truth and the author of
truth calls himself i am the way the
truth and the life it is of little
consequence how many hymns you sing how
much offering you turn in when you
reject truth you have rejected god you
can do it in a church building it is it
makes no difference to god his judgments
are worse upon those who claim to know
him and yet reject him by rejecting
truth samuel told saul because thou has
rejected the word of the lord he has
also rejected thee that is ample proof
that rejecting truth is rejecting god
you can reject truth and still accept
church but you cannot reject truth and
have god because god himself is truth
deuteronomy 32 4 god is truth john 14 6
jesus is truth first john 5 6 the holy
spirit is true when you reject truth you
reject god
and god's judgment must be poured out
because he does not judge that he's not
a fair god he's not a right god
righteousness includes judgment
and so the worst place you can be my
listening friend as painful as it is is
the wrong church
amen but jesus has a church because he
told peter upon this rock i will build
my church and the gifts of hell will not
prevail against it in acts chapter 7
verse 38 this is he that was with the
church in the wilderness the bible calls
the israelites in the wilderness under
moses's direction under god's direction
ultimately the church of god as he had
the church then he has a church of this
of christ and he has one now and they
all have the same distinguishing feature
obedience to god's divine law
amen
that was a ceremony by itself
right there um god is truth god is true
that's right
everything that he does is uh for
because of love and his judgments
because of love bring us back and even
at the end of times he will destroy the
wicked he won't punish him for eternity
um
next question number four in revelation
14 8 we see that babylon makes all
nations drink of the wine of the rat of
her fornication
what is that wine that makes the nations
drunk
wine in in in the bible not just
prophecy can refer to false truth
not it's not false truth false teaching
or the true teachings of god so it
refers to teaching doctrines when jesus
said in luke chapter 5 37 39 no man
peter new wine into all bottles christ
was referring to the fact that he came
to bring new light uh uh to refresh the
old teachings the jews misunderstood but
they were not changing and he said my
new teachings need to go into new people
people whose hearts are renewed but they
were refusing that and so wine
represents teachings doctrines truth
wine also represents error and so
babylon's wine is false teaching because
she made all nations drunk with the wine
of the wrath of a fornication the same
way
noah was made drunk by wine
in genesis chapter nine he was made
drunk let me preach another sermon
briefly when noah was made drunk by wine
noah did not know what was happening to
him
the person who abused him that person
knew what he was doing whatever the
abuse was
when lot had
sex with his two daughters they made him
drunk
they were not drunk you themselves they
were it was willful blatant flavor and
deliberate
wine is used as a way of separating
people from their senses and so when lot
was drunk did not know what was
happening then his daughter slept with
him babylon has made churches drunk
there are people in churches who are
drunk doctrinally they are drunk with
respect
to error and they have no clue they
simply believe if i make a lot of noise
if i shout loudly enough i'm filled with
the holy spirit of god the only evidence
of the the only reliable evidence the
only absolute evidence of the presence
of god is whether or not people are
following thus said the lord not even a
miracle is absolute proof that god is
present because the devil can perform
miracles and will perform miracles
according to second thessalonians
chapter two from verse nine and ten and
so
truth truth truth
is uh the the only thing that sustains
us and wine makes people drunk and the
people the drunk people are not even
aware they are drunk the leaders know
what they're doing most of them know
what they're doing but they keep the
people drunk so they can control the
people the truth of god brings you to
your senses let me say it again the
truth of god that's why jesus said the
truth shall make you free it brings you
to your senses david said open thou mine
eyes psalm 119 verse 130 the entrance of
thy word giveth light truth opens the
eyes and frees us from the bondage of
drunkenness and so babylon's crying is
that babylon made nations and rulers
drunk with the wine with false teaching
it's a very in the whole world
if you read uh revelation 12 verse 5 and
the great dragon was cast out not all
serpent called the devil and satan which
deceiveth the whole world deception is a
twisting of the truth that's why angels
followed satan revelation 12 9 because
they were deceived eve was deceived to
deceive you've got to meddle with the
truth of god and first john 5 19 and we
know that we are of god and the whole
world lies in wickedness virtually the
entire world is in a drunken state
because the entire world accepts error
babylon's crime
is that it has preached error and most
people follow errol
well
praise god for that answer buster
um
next question question number five
for what reason will vabylon receive got
seven last play
but the reason is in uh verse two
because she made all nations drink of
the wine of wrath of fornication now if
you go to uh
uh revelation 14 verse nine and the
third angel follow them say without
voice if any man worship the beast and
his image and receive his mark in his
forehead or in his hand the same shall
drink of the wine of the wrath of god
which is poured out without mixture into
the cup of his indignation this means
this by by the way revelation 49 through
11 the most frightful uh statement in
the entire bible let me say it again not
even the third of genesis chapter seven
and eight and nine eighty or seven and
eight it is the proclamation of
revelation fourteen nine three eleven
because god pulls out his wrath without
mercy why if any man worship the beast
and his image we know the beast is the
the people system an image is a system
set up that reflects the beast and part
of that will be apostate protestantism
and god says anyone who accepts that
system of error i will pour out upon you
my it is he does help my worst judgment
of those who rob banks even though
that's bad or steal cars or whatever
he's dealing with those who have made
religious choices in direct opposition
to thus save the lord those who have set
aside god's law for a man-made law they
received the worst of god's punishment
and so the reason that god's anger is
poured out and his anger is righteous it
is because a system has replaced him and
the bible speaks of abomination the
bible has sins then it has abominations
abomination is a concentrated form of
sin that makes god funded and the one
that does that is idolatry where you put
someone else in god's place and babylon
has done that and the beast that people
worship and the image of the beast that
people will worship these take gold
space in people's lives and god will
pour out his worst and most
most painful punishment but it will
still be an act of righteousness
promoting error and blinding people
deceiving people will be the reason
babylon will receive god's destructive
justice
amen
yes go ahead no go ahead
um
the truth make us free the the truth uh
open our eyes yes tell us to improve our
lives but this other system is trying to
put us down to deceive us to actually
kill us and god doesn't want that god
wants to be happy to be complete to be
whole
one of the ways to deceive people is to
withhold certain information from them
i mean governments do it corporations do
it businesses some churches do it just
withhold some information but jesus said
all things that i've heard of my father
i have made known unto you god doesn't
hide what we need he doesn't do that he
said if it were not so i would have told
you that's the way jesus functions he
tells you what you need to know
to keep people in error you have to hide
the truth from them you hide the truth
you deliberately hide the truth and the
result is error deception and that's
what babylon has been doing and is doing
and god has to put a stop to that
amen thank you pastor they are there
there are preachers in sunday churches
who know if they're listening to me now
they know the sabbath is saturday sunset
friday to sunset saturday and they will
not preach it because they don't want to
lose the congregation and the offering
but they know the sabbath is saturday
but they will not appreciate and if
they're listening to me they ought to
have the courage with god's help to come
out and say the seventh day is the
sabbath even if you lose your church
lose your church but don't lose heaven
never contribute to someone's
destruction contribute to someone's
salvation and the promotion of error is
an unforgivable contribution to
someone's destruction
wow that's definitely not love in your
neighbor withholding this
i give back the
microphone to the nation
thank you so much brother kevin gomez
for posing those questions adding the
commentary and as always thank you elder
skeet for expounding on those questions
zeroing in on the wine of the wrath of
babylon why babylon is receiving the
plagues for withholding truth from god's
people
and you know one of the saddest verses
in the bible in my opinion is jeremiah
51 verse 9. here's what the bible says
we would have healed babylon
but she is not healed
forsake her and let us go everyone into
his own country for her judgment
reacheth unto heaven and it's lifted up
to the skies friends there is a bomb in
gilead and for those that may still be
in babylon friends god is giving us the
opportunity to come out and one of the
reasons that babylon has fallen in that
they will receive the plagues of god
goddess because they have not accepted
the atoning sacrifice of jesus christ
but have substituted his place with
false doctrine
let us choose truth
let us choose to be healed
all right
let's move on to the next two questions
that we have on our topic the next one
is well we have definitely answered this
does god have people in babylon and who
are those people
yes well repetition is good so let's
deal with that again but let me pray
first father as we continue please
direct all of our minds i pray put your
words literally in my mouth your ideas
in my mind and the humility of christ in
my heart in jesus name i pray amen
yes god has people in babylon he does
jesus said in john chapter 10 for verse
of the sheep i have
which are not of this fold
them also i must bring now there's
something called sheep stealing which
all pastors hey don't take my members
but jesus i hate to say jesus sheep
steal he doesn't steal but christ came
to bring people out of false systems he
said look i have
she in other foals i've got to bring
them of course he brings them with us
said the lord of the sheep i have which
are not of this fall and someone
listening to me may come under that
description
them also i must bring and they shall
hear my voice now wait a minute what is
the voice of god this is the voice of
god right here they shall hear my voice
and there shall be one fold and one
shepherd so yes and the powerful cry of
revelation 18 4
come out of her my people that he be not
partakers of his sins and that he
received not of her plagues for her sins
have reached unto heaven and god hath
remembered their iniquities and when god
remembers it means he's about to act and
so we uh god has people in babylon but
the message of revelation 46-12 will
bring them out and that message is
amplified by the message of revelation
18 1-5 god has people and when people
hear the message they will come i got a
text last week from a lady she said i've
been listening to your messages and i've
accepted the truth i've become assembly
advocates i got a text from a lady in
nigeria she said i've been listening to
your messages
how can i become a senior i want them to
obey god and from time to time i get
messages like that because when the
truth touches the heart of a sincere
person the person may not know
everything but even a little pebble of
truth when it touches the sensei heart
it leads an impression and that person
is moved by god's spirit to act
so god has people in babylon and they
will come up also let me give you the
sad side of that god has people in his
church who will leave
because when we read from first timothy
four verse one now the spirit speaks
especially in the latter time some shall
depart from the faith there'll be a
going and coming a going and coming
but you know paul tells us in the second
thessalonians two verse
let no man deceive you by any means for
this for that that they shall not come
except they come are falling away first
there will be there will be a um
direction movement in two directions
people leaving truth and people coming
to truth my listening friend wherever
you are be part of the movement toward
truth because to leave truth is to leave
life to leave truth is to leave god and
so god has people in churches that
disregard god by disregarding his law he
will call them out and when they hear
the word they will come because my sheep
know my voice they may be in the long
flock but they know my voice when they
hear it they'll come
and what brings them the message
that's the voice of god today the
message
that's right that's right you're
adulterated
the law of god get out of that church
even if it worships on sabbath if it
minimizes the law of god find another
church
this is the crime of the angel lutherans
minimizing god's law this was the crime
of sodom and gomorrah minimizing god's
law this was the crime of babylon under
that nebuchadnezzar destroyed minimizing
god's law this is why the northern
kingdom went into captivity minimizing
god's law this is why new testament
banner was destroyed minimizing god's
law by minimizing the law giver it is
the minimizing the disregarding of the
law of god because the disregard of god
is to disregard the law given jesus
christ
no matter what else you may say if they
do they worship me teaching for doctor
the commandments of men we have the
commandments of many commandments of god
if worshipping by the commandments of
men is useless then worshiping based on
god's commandments that is acceptable to
god simple
reasoning and god has people who realize
have been worshipping god ignorantly and
falsely i need to get out and find
myself in a system where the law of god
is respected christ is safe here yes but
he saves me from breaking his law and he
brings me to the place where i my
testimony becomes i'd like to do thy
will or my god yet thy law is within my
heart
any system that undermines god's law
that's what it comes down to
satan's object of opposition has always
been god's law
that's what is take away the lord the
devil has no problem with you me or
anybody else take away the god law he
has no problem the law is what sticks
with his cross and that's why for
hundreds of years he's fought this
battle and he uses religious systems to
advance his cause
all right dr mccarthy next question
amen amen i'm tempted as you were
talking about the law and how vital it
is how it is to the core i'm thinking
about the human body that god created
and how the law is the foundation the
framework just like our bones the
skeleton structure everything is built
on the bones and if we destroy the bones
we destroy the tissue all right the law
is foundational
all right
next question
what is the role of god's people in the
final call made to babylon in revelation
chapter 8. very important question
father in heaven continue to speak
through all of us i pray and if there's
someone listening who's under conviction
move that person to accept the truth in
jesus name i pray amen the role of god's
people has always been the same since
adam's sin when god called abraham in
genesis 12 3 he said
i will bless them that bless thee well
let's read for verse one now the lord
has said unto abram get thee out of thy
country and from thy kindred and from
thy father's house unto a lamb that i
will show thee and i will make of thee a
great nation and i will bless you and
make thy name great and thou shalt be a
blessing now what was a specific
blessing abraham was to be verse 3 gives
us a clue and i will bless them that
bless thee and curse him that cursing
thee and in thee shall all families of
the earth be blessed if you read acts 3
25 26 that blessing was deliverance from
sin and so the blessing of abraham was
the blessing of a messiah to come to
deliver people from sin he delivered
them before he came he'd live them after
he came he delivers them now and so the
blessing that god's people are to be to
the world the function that we must
carry out is by proclaiming the truth we
call people out of false systems of
worship it is not our voice that calls
them it is the voice of truth but god
uses us like microphones like megaphones
like a loudspeaker so people can hear
the message of truth and truth alone
sanctifies error does not sanctify so
our function our function as god's
people is unashamedly and without
hesitation to issue the loud cry which
is come out of her my people come out of
what come out of a system that
disregards law god by disregarding his
law and you disregard god's law by
simply disregarding one there's no need
to disregard all my you effectively do
so by disregarding one we're calling
people out of systems that may of not
affect the law of god this is the role
of god's people they must make that call
but they must live the call that they
make so that the life they live is the
power
of the call of course that power being
the spirit of god working through them
so yes we must preach the truth but we
must also live the truth so when your
co-workers observe you at the office
your colleagues observing the classroom
or wherever
that is part of issuing the call
and that call must be bold
because there's little time left this
call must be bold
i didn't say harsh i said bold so no one
is confused did he say the seventh day
the sabbath yes that's what i said why
did you say that the bible says
amen amen amen the same way abraham god
called abraham to make him a blessing
you see god did not call abraham for his
own sake god called abraham that god
might use him to bless others no one is
ever called for his oral say we are
called to be a blessing to others we
just can't live our lives ourselves we
are called by god tremendous honor to
proclaim a message by voice on my
lifestyle
because the end is near it really is
so true you know elder skeet sometimes i
think if the president of the united
states wants to say you know i have a
job for you to do denisha come join me
or i have a job for you to do john come
join me we would feel so important oh
yes
of the united states
but the creator of the universe yes
calls us
and says come
do my work work with me i have a channel
for you to do what not humble and high
privilege yes yes
and we're rejected
have mercy
well
other skate we have come to the end of
the court questions for our q a
and we'll be transitioning into the open
forum questions i know i sent you a long
list of questions this morning from
stream facts i think i may take two or
three because i also have to speak
um not too long after this live stream
um but and i also see that mark alex
also you put a question in the chat but
we'll take one question from before and
then we'll take your question brother
mark and welcome rose to the sda church
we pray that you are blessed by this
ministry and that you will continue to
learn and grow um in the knowledge of
our lord and savior
so we'll take this question this
question comes from michael he says i am
23 years old and from ghana
i have been i have been battling with
the issue of profits over the years
i would like to know if the seventh-day
adventist church
aside from the ministry of ellen g white
has other people who are called by god
to be prophets in these last days and
first corinthians chapter 12 verse 28 is
quoted which reads
and god has set some in the church these
apostles secondary prophets
teachers
and miracles then gifts of healings
healths governments diversities of
tongues
yes well that's true and this the bible
shows that to be the case god has had
prophets from enoch
as far as we are right until ellen white
which is a prophet in our church the
church does not recognize anyone as a
prophet since ellen white if god sends a
prophet to the church he will somehow
let the church know he doesn't just let
some one person on that side he will let
his church know through his ordained
system and so we are not aware of any
prophet to the seventh-day adventist
church since ellen white will pass away
in 1915 after seven years of faithful
service but the gift of prophecy has not
yet ended god may elect or choose to
raise up someone else but as far as your
church is aware and the church knows
since ellen white ended the ministry of
god called her to rest there has not
been a specifically called prophet now
in if you know these are the churches
everybody's a prophet the prophet john
and prophet this and prophet indonesia
everybody's a prophet you say but god
has not raised up a prophet in this
earth since alawite not someone the
church has recognized now from time to
time even the otherwise did it were
people calling themselves prophets and
some leaders will listen to them but the
church has never recognized anyone since
loy and the church is god's system for
recognizing when god is doing this or
that so no we don't recognize any other
prophets since l why now god speaks to
people in different ways yes but the
discrete officer prophet we've had not
had not had one since ellen white died
in 1915.
and if you don't know whoever white is
please find out read her writing first
book i recommend steps to christ please
read it steps to christ
next question
this question comes from by the way let
me say this if someone comes to you
saying i'm a prophet say excuse me and
just walk away
please
prophets are not self-appointed
the world is overrun with self-appointed
particularly in africa and other places
everyone is a prophet
if someone says so i'm a prophet you say
okay god bless you walk away before the
person puts error into your head
prophets do not call themselves let me
be very clear they are called by god
no prophet
who is any prophet at all will come to
you saying i am a prophet mm-hmm
it reminds me of satan's last great
deception when he says i'm jesus and
jesus
well he won't be the first one we have a
lot of people who call themselves jesus
and those who follow them end up dead
in disgraceful ways
next question
hi everyone this comes from mark alex hi
everyone i am from nairobi kenya
in
in that okay in what regard i guess why
did jesus change water to wine from my
research and according to most seven-day
adventist pastors they say it is grape
juice
you see the bible cannot condemn wine as
it does in the book of proverbs if you
look at wine now why did jesus turn grip
watered wine because there was a need
for that wine at the time and everything
christ did he did because the father
told him
and he says that very clearly everything
the father jesus did or said he did and
said because the father told him so the
father told him to perform that miracle
we're introduced to wine in uh genesis
chapter 9
then in genesis chapter 19 and in
genesis 14 in nine
wine and bread and in 19 we have lot and
his daughters
so so wine has a long history in the
bible
jesus the bible is supposed to
whine as an alcoholic beverage because
it is harmful for the body
grape juice we call it wine but it's not
really wine in the common sense of wine
you go to the store you buy some wine
you want to bring you grape juice you
bring your alcoholic beverage
our bodies are tempted to hold ghosts
and alcohol has negative effects there's
some people who say well research shows
a glass of wine has this benefit and
that benefit but no wine at all has even
more benefits so the further glass of
wine we have this or that benefit does
not make it good jesus had to have
changed that water into the wine which
is the fruit of the vine not the
alcoholic beverage that makes people
drunk and lose control of their senses
which was used by lot's daughters and of
course by noah's son and who told him to
do it the father told him to do it
because jesus said he only did and said
what the father told him to do and say
you can read that in john 7 26-28
john 12 48-50 john 14 10 where jesus
said i only sin do while the father
tells me to say unto
god will not supply something that is
injurious to one's health and alcohol is
amen and i forget the exact devotional
book but ellen white speaks about the um
miracle at cana
notes that the wine that jesus turned
the water into was unfermented
all right so we are going to move on to
our next question
okay
let me say this yes when people want to
do something they try to twist the bible
to support what they want to do
people who want to drink they try to say
well the bible supports wine people who
want to smoke they say the bible says
this people want several wives the bible
says that that's a terrible crime
against the bible
don't use the bible to support your
carnal desires leave god's word out of
it please
all right amen
uh this next question says can you help
me get a better answer from pastor skeet
i do not seem to understand when the
lesson talks about resting in peace
yet the dead know nothing
from the biblical standpoint all the
dead are the same knowing nothing so
every dead person is in the same state i
guess the person is saying how do we
reconcile resting the dead resting in
peace
and not knowing anything
well rest is no different from sleep the
bible says death is asleep the bible
uses history to describe death
when the disciples told jesus and
lazarus was sick jesus said lazarus
sleepeth that's what jesus said a
sleeping person is a resting person now
we know the dead know nothing but it
does not change the fact the bible
describes death as a sleep so we can
understand and so when people see a rest
in peace they're not saying the person
is alive
they're simply saying we hope you've
passed away in jesus and when he comes
you take you home that's all the person
is saying rest in peace is an expression
it is not a doctrinal declaration it's
an expression rest in peace
but the bible says death is asleep from
which god will wake the righteousness of
the wicked the righteous to go home with
him the wicked to receive the final
destruction but yes the dead know
nothing we know that a sleeping person
knows nothing either
a drunk person knows nothing either by
the way
a lot of people have been abused in a
state of drunkenness and realize it only
when they became sober so a lot of
conditions in which we know nothing when
you sleep when you get drunk we know
nothing
but
the special resting piece is merely a
traditional saying which means i hope
you lie in christ and may he take you to
his kingdom when he comes
amen amen
all right i'll take this next question
i think i may even make it the last
question all right let's see
okay this is a good day please i need
the answer to this question urgently in
anticipating
a response or a reply and also
will like pastor randy skeet to answer
i am a college student
i'm a student in college this in the
country nigeria but due to the presence
of a corrupt system and greedy lecturers
in my school some illegally made it
compulsory for certain amounts of money
to be paid before a student could submit
his or her practical reports or
assignments is it a sin to pay such
money using the biblical explanation in
regard to bribery and extortion yes it's
a sin
now i realize you value your education
very highly and you're looking forward
to your degrees you can have a good job
there is no justification for violating
or drifting from dust set the lord the
bible speaks against bribes we must not
accept or pay bribes or accept bribes if
it is not if it's the poll not the po it
cannot be an official policy if some
corrupt teacher has introduced that as a
way of making money you cannot where you
can do it but you'd be wrong you must
not do it christians need to understand
doing right must be the standard we
follow even at the loss of life
and if daniel was willing to lose his
life to be fearful to god the three
hebrew boys were willing to lose their
life you must be willing to lose a
degree to be faithful to god do not pay
bribes to teachers don't do that put the
matter in god's hands and leave it in
god's hand your god is god your god is
not that degree god can take care of you
with or without a degree i'm not against
degrees i'm against compromising for the
sake of the degree like taking exams on
seven for the sake of the degree
on the god in first samuel two verse
thirty i hope the person will read this
verse them that only me i will honor
believe that and honor god do not pay a
bribe or accept one
amen amen
all right i you know i'll make this the
final question and then elder stephen
close out okay this is a good day i'm a
seven-day adventist i would like to ask
if religion can really save us because
i'm also hearing that question from
others and i also asked myself about
that and i had nothing to say uh like
like can it be found in the bible please
enlighten me thank you in advance be
healthy and god bless
religion saves noah
we're saved by christ
isaiah 45 22 look unto me and be saved
all the ends of the earth acts 4 12
neither is the any other name under
heaven give whereby we must be saved
you're only saved by jesus john 5 48 you
will not come unto me that he might be
saved christ is the savior but christ
has a church
he has a church
acts 7 verse 38 in matthew 16 18 he has
a church the gifts of hell shall not
prevail against it he has a church and
the church of christ is the church where
the the righteousness of christ is
uplifted where the law of god is
respected and obeyed through the power
of the holy spirit christ has a church
and so christ takes saved people and
puts them in a church so the church is a
group of people who've accepted christ
who live by the doctrines of christ the
teachings of christ which is genesis and
revelation but religion itself cannot
save you because satanism is a religion
and that will save no one in the kingdom
of god are you following me there are
heathen religions there are pagan
religions that do not recognize the god
of heaven and earth the word religion
should not have a magical effect upon
your mind the word truth should affect
your mind the church of god is the
church that produces truth
so yes god has a church but it is christ
that saves but christ saves us to obey
him he saves us he's our savior we obey
him because he's our lord but he's both
at the same time a religion does not
save you because those who say crucify
him were very faithful to their religion
but they tried to kill god they told
pilate we have a law and by our law he
ought to die john 19 verse 7 we try to
use the law to kill the law giver
religion does not save but jesus has a
religion he has a church and he said the
gates of hell shall not reveal against
it because the gates of hell cannot
prevail against truth
amen amen
powerful
friends let's take the side of truth
today
we see that is really the distinguishing
mark
those that are in babylon have rejected
truth while god's people have accepted
and lived by truth and we know jesus is
truth
elder skeet we extend many thanks to you
for your time for grace with your
presence and energy once more we pray
that the lord will continue to shower
you your wife and entire family with his
goodness and his grace and may he go
before you and continue to order your
steps in his word
let me say this quickly
before you go any further
yes it has been demonstrated by research
i don't want to treat research as a god
but research has its place they
demonstrate that when someone adopts a
physician
new life seldom makes a difference to
that person when someone adopts a
position you bring all the new light you
want they won't change they usually
don't change this is why sometimes i am
so direct and come across as being so
forceful sometimes you've got to hit
people between the eye with a
sledgehammer of truth to wake them up
not get someone's attention a brick
between their eyes
you know that's why i talk to where i
talk sometimes because there's some
people you show them this is black and
they say white because they're so custom
they grow up being told this is why even
though they see black you tell them it's
black they will say white and so
sometimes you've got to be forceful
you've got to grab them by the lapels
and shake them up a little bit in love
to get them to understand you're on the
path to hell can't you see that open
your eyes you know jesus said in
frustration why do you not understand my
speech even because you cannot hear my
words john 8 43 he seemed baffled they
could not understand what he's saying
you know he tells the israelites why
will he die ezekiel 33 why are you dying
and so sometimes you're going to speak
to people why are you keeping sunday
when you have no bible verse why do you
keep doing that why won't you change it
keep god's sabbath day the seventh day
why and so sometimes you've got to knock
people up against the head in level
spores to save them so that's why
sometimes i'm a little forceful it's not
because i'm harsh i'm not harsh tall i'm
a nice man says indonesia i'm sure
you'll say it then but sometimes you're
going to be forceful for the salvation
of people's souls and i'm finished now
god bless you my lovely sister god bless
you all those who were part of the
program and who listened
amen amen thank you so much elvis yes
indeed you are a very very nice man god
bless you god bless you god bless you
to those of you that have been watching
online i see rose mentioned you before
thank you for tuning in mark is still
from trinidad and tobago
uh who else is here yes
bossier able from nairobi kenya also
mark alex from nairobi kenya thank you
all for tuning in and joining two
brother kevin gomez thank you so much
for asking those questions adding the
commentary keeping the fire going sister
stacy and i know you'll be doing a
closing prayer so thank you in advance
for doing that and for moderating the
chat
to my mom as always thank you for your
support prayers and counsel for sharing
this live those of you that are watching
feel free to share
like and subscribe so you are notified
whenever we go live and so that the word
of god can reach near and far
now you mentioned kenya
the only country mentioned so let me say
greetings to all my kenyan brothers and
sisters who are listening i must scan
you a lot maybe one day god will open
the way with this pandemic me to return
but god bless kenya all kenyans and any
other country represented or listening
may god bless you in your countries
amen thank you so much elder skeet
now
i know we've spoken a lot about truth
we've spoken about uh allowing ourselves
to not only hear the truth and to speak
the truth but to also
live the truth now this song for the
jonathan and i have recorded it is
called my tribute to god be the glory
and i pray that you are blessed
and encouraged by this selection
what happened
okay
stupid
[Music]
ah
can i say thanks
for the
things you
have done
for me
things
deserved
[Music]
yet you give to prove
your love
for me
the
voices
of a
million
angels could
not express
my gratitude
all that i am
and ever hope to be
i
owe it all
to
thee
god be the glory
[Music]
to
god be the glory
god
be the glory
for the things
he has done
with his blood
he has
saved me
with his power
he
has raised
me
to
god be
the glory
for the faith
[Music]
lord let it be pleasing pleasing
lord to me
and should i gain
any
let it go to
[Music]
with his blood
[Applause]
[Music]
he
has
be the glory
for the things
he
has
done
[Music]
thank y'all now turn it over to sister
stacy and to do our closing prayer
amen let us pray
the heavenly merciful father we want to
thank you so much for this opportunity
where we have vast in the truth
of your word
we pray there lord that you continue to
bless your man's servant as he continues
month after month
expounding on the word of god
i pray that all the hearts of your
children today that we may receive your
word that good seed
and help our
hearts to be that good ground
and bring forth much fruits
bless your daughter sister mccurchion as
she continues to be a blessing and to
lead out according to your will
and bless all those that have been part
of this up this presentation today
and even those that will hear in the
future
bless them as well
and as your man servant rightfully said
help your children to hear you
and follow the lamb wherever you lead us
thank you again we pray in jesus name
amen and amen
amen thank you so much sister stacy anne
to all of you that have joined
commented like shared all of all of our
friends and supporters god bless you may
the name of the lord be praised and ever
glorified in our lives all right
everyone thank you and